but it's an extraordinary thing I think
to see you know older by
um our ancestors anti-setters um and
anti-cessors the the the results of
Austria's robustus making these
extraordinary completely sphere
crystalline rocks a desire to shape a
desire to shape even before language and
I think that's been with us forever art
as a way of working directly with the
world this isn't about making images
it's about actually forming
and I still believe that sculpture is an
extraordinary art form because it's not
about making a picture of something it's
about making something that didn't exist
before and putting it in the world by
implication the world changes I believe
that it is a fundamental in a way Act of
hope that means that things can change
and hopefully get better
um I think we live in an extraordinary
time in which art has been through the
culture industry
institutionalized on the one hand that
we think that we have to go to museums
to see art when actually for most of it
for most of uh our species Sapien
sapiens history has been something that
we did together that we experience
together whether that was telling the
stories of the tribe or telling somebody
what you've just done in the day as we
we three have done uh getting to know
each other
the the idea that art is somehow just a
natural part of living as natural as as
as breathing or the beating of our heart
we go we we go to shows we go to shows
in which sculpture has to play the game
of theater might be on for a month might
be on for six weeks
but here
that capability of sculpture to make
place
is ignored and in its place we see in a
way a a demonstration of works that have
been taken from a a studio and put in
this artificial environment uh with the
hope that maybe
um they will perhaps be bought or I'm in
a in a yeah commercial show that that
would be the Hope or that they will be
as it were intellectually understood was
a very different thing from maybe the
history of our
Cathedrals which were always open which
were there day and night you know the
Great West fronts of so many Cathedrals
I've just done a piece for Winchester
West Front there are
297 life-size sculptures made in the
13th century that are there rain and
shine night and day in public View
I just I just wonder what happened to
our relationship to art that we now
think of it as a status symbol when in
fact it was just a way of living
and and you have made
the Angel of the North so many of those
great sculptures that you have come up
with on the beach and you know in in the
northwest coast
you want art to be just there as part of
our everyday experience you don't have
to go to a gallery or a museum
yeah I think I think it's sort of been
made into something that's sort of
supposed to be good for you and uh yeah
here's here's here's the angel I mean
that was that was an extraordinary
experience making that because actually
I couldn't make it on my own this is
this is in a way a a return to a kind of
pre-modern idea of how how art could be
made and who it was for this was made by
finding all the shipwrights that that
had been making ships but were told by
Margaret Thatcher that they were no
longer relevant and the shipyards along
with them with all of the the mining the
coal mining kind of were disappeared and
here was something a totemic object that
in some way
is a is a is a teddy bear for this
terrible transition between the
purposefulness of a of a of a industrial
community
transitioning to the information age and
it was a way of just saying no you do
have a future look this is what we have
this is what we the language that we
have learned what we can make
that actually shows that we have the
confidence in our own future and it's
been an amazing thing it's it's it sits
on top of this mound
and shares it with the people that come
and it's it's very rarely alone
it's also become a
Landmark if I'm driving up you know
North oh around properly in the north
now when I see it and it and it's it's
part of our kind of
were you worried about how it would be
received and whether you know people
would accept no everything is a I think
an experiment it's a test of what what
sculpture can do and it is that you know
I I think that this is an amazing thing
that it is somehow it has become I don't
know how many of you live in England but
it has sort of become part of our
subconscious in in in a curious way you
can't you can't make a policy to to to
say that but it it it suggests to me
that actually there is still that need
for in a way objects that re-root us
that tell us about where we've been and
maybe also invite us to think about the
future so
let's stick with the
tonight's debate how do you see art in
today's world
and how it will develop and how it will
change particularly in the short term
and maybe over the long much longer term
well I think I mean what what again the
lesson of covid was that people suddenly
um weren't getting on planes in order to
relax
um they were getting to know their
neighborhood and people were looking in
their environment in a way that they
they maybe hadn't noticed before it
wasn't just about going to the corner
shop but also sort of seeing what the
texture of the of of you know the
buildings that they mainly they'd never
looked at before and through that
process they also discovered yeah
imaginative objects that were in their
environment that they maybe hadn't known
before and I'm I guess my hope my
aspiration is that that you know that
fact of art becoming in a way
institutionalized and only seen through
museums and art being commercialized and
only being seen in a way as items of
High Capital exchange can be replaced
with as it were the older model as art
to be lived with and that um we will we
will see a flowering of serious works of
art that are that take their place as it
were in the collective spaces of our
world Anthony the the classic question
of a pollster is to say are you
optimistic or pessimistic about the
future and I'm just wondering where you
stand on that given what you say is the
commoditization of Art and the fact that
it's you know just something that high
net worth individuals can have and then
trade for something even more money
against what you've just said about the
ideal vision
of Art in the public space I I think
that we we all each and every one of us
is in some senses a creator of the
future I think that art is an instrument
through which I think that potential can
be realized
uh I I think that we have all each of us
got to make up our own minds about the
value system that we that we ascribe to
at the moment we're all in a late
capitalist World in which our human
purpose is only seen in terms of Market
productivity and that's just a a
disaster I think that uh you know in in
facing climate change in facing uh
population expansion in facing our
responsibilities for a sustainable
future whether our our species will
actually continue to contribute to the
evolution of the biosphere rather than
destroying it these are questions that
each of us have to ask ourselves and I
believe that art has an absolutely
fundamental role in that I think that
we're in a mess at the moment and we're
seeing all of the hopes of of
globalization replaced by as it were
market economies that are actually uh
yeah through nationalism and and and
kind of competition actually
disintegrate rating what the world wide
web and Moe's World promised us that
actually we were going to get this
instrument that that led us to be more
together to see as it were give give us
the instrument of a positive creative uh
future uh I I'm afraid that I'm I'm I'm
uncertain uh deeply uncertain about
about the future and certainly the the
situation in Ukraine is an example of us
going backwards to actually you know
medieval or Paleolithic ways of settling
difference uh so
um
I am I am probably on the side of
pessimism uh but uh answer yeah well
look we're going to come back to some of
these themes
um a little later on in the discussion I
know that probably the tension in the
room about what that first vote looks
like has been unbearable for you so I
think I am now able to put you out of
your misery and I can give you uh the
results that the the further first five
years will it be better or worse uh 37
say yes 54 say no uh nine percent
undivided there we are we've got the
graphics there everything uh 50 years uh
59 say it's going to be a better place
19 say it won't be uh 22 percent
undecided I love the fact that people
are so confident to predict what 500
years on will look like uh 38 yes 24 no
38 percent
undecided
I think the most interesting part about
that is that we're pretty pessimistic
well that we're pretty pessimistic about
what the fight for the first next five
years look like but the next 50 years
somebody else's responsibility yeah
maybe the psychology of that is um
fascinating
um so I think that's really really
interesting Clover let me come to you
now because you've dedicated yourself to
you know climate action arguing that we
shouldn't feel powerless in the face of
the climate crisis
so
we've seen those numbers there what's
your short term prognosis for what the
world looks like for the next five years
and welcome and thank you for being here
thank you for having me
um
I think it helps to look to the Past
before we try to project into the future
and
our planet is 4.6 billion years old
thereabout now if we scale that down to
a number that I can understand let's say
46 years right humans have been here for
about four hours
the Industrial Revolution started one
minute ago
and in the past 60 seconds we've
destroyed over half of the world's
forests
in the past 10 seconds we've wiped out
two-thirds of our world's wildlife
our lives are fleeting and yet if we
look at what we've done to our
environment what we've done to
communities
in the context of our planet
it is quite remarkable how quickly we
are making ourselves The Architects of
our own demise
and when I was asked this question will
the world be a better place the first
thing I thought was well for whom
because over the next five ten years
the world will be better
for the top one percent of the one
percent the rich will get richer
technologies that were designed to make
our lives easier and better will do the
opposite they will line the pockets of a
few they will further create divide
socially and politically among the rest
of us
and if the science is to go by
we are going to continue to hurdle
toward this Cliff of climate collapse
and we are going to continue to struggle
to let go of the old Paradigm a
capitalist system based on Limitless
growth with finite resources
and those who have both created this
system and also been conditioned into it
are going to grip that much tighter even
as signs of breakdown show up all around
us
okay five years 50 years
I mean by the time I'm 50 uh it's
estimated that we will have a billion
climate migrants
it's estimated that 90 of the world's
coral reefs will be dead
uh so the prognosis Is Not Great John
um and I'm not particularly optimistic
purely because it is my job to read the
science every day and to listen to the
scientists who are screaming at the top
of their lungs trying to wake Society up
to this absolute climate emergency and
yet unfortunately the reality is that
those of us who live in a bubble of
climate privilege like myself living in
London you know we will continue to
avoid the worst impacts of climate
breakdown and the people on the front
lines of this crisis who are already
paying the price who are contributing
the least to Global emissions the least
to ecological catastrophe they are going
to continue to experience the worst
impacts like the millions of people in
India for example who are currently
facing life-threatening drought and heat
so it's not positive however I would not
be doing any of this work if I did not
have hope and that hope for me having
participated in cop and Global decision
making processes does not lie with
people in closed door rooms it lies with
people in the streets it lies with this
Grassroots mobilization that is
happening I've spoken to so many leaders
within companies over the past couple of
years who have chosen to give up the top
salaries and all of the benefits because
they're having this existential crisis
you know we talk about the great
resignation of young people leaving
companies but more and more CEOs are
stepping aside and saying actually I
want to work for a companies and
organizations that are Purpose Driven
and in 50 years time it is my generation
of climate generation who are going to
be in these seats of power so I
absolutely have hope that huge
transformation is capable and yet
because of the science this next 10-year
window is absolutely critical for our
capacity to take the action that is
needed at the scale and at the pace that
is required yeah I think one of the
things that really strikes me is the
leadership actually now coming from
boardrooms
more so than from politicians on some of
the most intractable so which is a you
know it's downward pressure from their
staff and their customers saying we want
you to do something about this so that
is a cause of optimism yeah I mean a
huge part of what uh force of nature
does our organization
um is putting young people into
boardrooms enabling young people to walk
the corridors of power because one of
the things that we see time and time
again is that there is this real crisis
in imagination in the context of climate
you know I think
um we spend so much energy articulating
the problem which is what we have to do
but we don't often take pause and think
well what are we working toward and what
does a different system look like and I
believe that young people have a unique
Advantage because it because we haven't
been conditioned to the status quo
because we haven't had you know the
wings of our imaginations clipped so we
have that capacity to actually say how
might we rethink our food system or our
Energy System or how we get around a
city right and so we need that
disruptive thinking we need that
capacity to speak to the climate crisis
from a place of moral and ethical
imperatives to disrupt the incumbent
thinking which is too often ensnared
within well where's the business
opportunity here and
briefly Clover finally
500 years take us to you know 25 22.
yeah I mean this is a hard one
um I think would be a little audacious
to try and articulate what the future
will look like in 500 years but
if we look back 500 years
European colonialists were just starting
the global slave trade right and we look
back in horror at what our ancestors did
five centuries ago
and yet I also feel that our descendants
500 years from now are going to look
back on us in much the same way
they're going to
Wonder
how it is that we severed ourselves so
completely from nature
they're going to ask
how was it that you sacrificed billions
of animals every single year so that you
could enjoy a turkey at Christmas or a
Big Mac on a night out
how was it that you clear-cut
million-year-old forests so that you
could buy a bottle of shampoo or a
chocolate bar
how is it that you allowed the most
vulnerable people in your Society to pay
the cost
so that the very top one percent could
profit from the commodification of
nature from the exploitation of those
communities so I have faith that our
descendants will deeply understand
Consciousness and sentience and Soul and
Spirit in a way that our current Society
has not been conditioned to and I think
they will look back
in horror
but I think the actions that we take
over the next 10 20 50 100 years
have to set up a future civilization
Society
who is inevitably going to be
um you know flying on rocket ships and
be into Galactic but for the most part
we'll find the most interesting Frontier
not discovering new planets but
discovering the inner Frontier doing the
inner work understanding our psychology
understanding how we're deeply
interrelated and interconnected with the
magical tapestry of life that is all
around us
fabulous
I want to come to Timo now to talk about
Clover for for prime minister seriously
yeah seriously I think
honestly wow wow
it was fabulous it's serious yeah
I have nothing to say actually
actually you know that gives me optimism
actually hearing you articulate that so
clearly in the involvement of young
people in so much of this which is I'm
sure vital but let me come to you now
because I want to talk about Ai and the
role of AI in shaping our future but
maybe it would be good if we just where
are we now with AI
how is it affecting our lives today
um yeah I think we are completely
oblivious to the fact that they're all
around us I don't know who you are what
you did today but I can guarantee you
you dealt with 50 machines today that
were each smarter than you and what they
were assigned to do and you're going to
be dealing with 500 tomorrow and 5 000
the day after and the interesting bit is
that
um they are all the result of capitalism
like Sir Anthony said uh you know I I in
my book I talk about something that's
called the three inevitables and the
first inevitable is that AI will happen
there's no stopping it even though
people like Elon Musk will say the
danger of AI is more than nukes more
than nuclear weapons it will continue to
happen because of capitalism because of
we've built uh
um sort of a prisoner's dilemma that
basically makes sure that if Google
develops AI Facebook will develop AI if
China develops AI you know Russia is
going to develop Ai and America is going
to develop Ai and so we're stuck in this
and I think the interesting challenge is
most people don't understand the
exponential function which I think
Clover has articulated super well
what happened in the last 100 years of
development of Technology happens almost
every day now right and and and the
technology acceleration curve looks like
this so what the AI we have today which
took since 1956 to develop will double
in its capacity in the next 56 days and
then double again in you know 27 days
and so are we in the infancy of AI we
are so so I I literally compare them to
a one and a half year old infant but a
prodigy a one and a half year old
Prodigy that is learning not from trying
a few cubes to fit within square holes
and round holes but from billions and
billions and billions of data points and
five years 50 years
so I actually will say openly can I
start from 500 years yeah I do is that
way you lie so I have almost an absolute
certainty that in 500 years will be in a
very good place
okay uh interestingly what Humanity the
civilization we've built is the result
of our intelligence okay intelligence is
not a bad thing
the problems we've created is the result
of our stupidity
simple as that huh to take art and lock
it in capitalist uh uh you know walls is
stupid to to destroy the planet at the
expense of making money is absolute
Insanity right so more intelligence is
actually good for us more intelligence
will solve the big problems in ways that
are actually quite good for us and and I
I say that artificial intelligence is
about seven years away from surpassing
Human intelligence so 2029 by most
predictions the the smartest being on
planet Earth is not going to be a human
anymore right it's going to be a machine
but my observation is that the smartest
being on planet Earth has never been a
human the smartest being on planet Earth
is life itself
and life the difference between between
humans and and Life Is Life creates
through abundance right I don't need to
kill the Tigers to survive for for life
to survive you want more Tigers you want
more deers you want more poop you want
more trees you want more everything
right and and so this is very
intelligent if you ask me to create
almost out of nothing with abundance
it's a very interesting approach and
when the machines surpass our
intelligence they will end up there they
will end up in a place where they will
not need to destroy Humanity or destroy
anything to create okay there's a
question around our relevance in that
environment to be honest but but
definitely it will be an environment
where we can solve climate change
because we first will make the right
decisions and second we'll have the
right right technology the right mindset
the right intelligence to solve it so so
to to start 500 years time it's a Utopia
you can walk to a tree and pick an app
will walk to another tree and pick an
iPhone everything's fine
yeah but isn't there good intelligence
and bad intelligence I mean Anthony was
talking a moment there isn't no there
but you know the horror of Ukraine where
that's gonna block you well one person
has decided yes that's not the question
of intelligence John the the this is
this is a question of morals so we don't
make decisions based on our intelligence
we make decisions based on our value set
as informed by our intelligence but I
suppose the question I'm getting at is
Will AI be able to override stupidity
you're that's so that's the core of our
five and 50 years right the core of and
please don't hate me I'm just the
messenger here and and like you rightly
said I left because I realized what we
were building right
um we're not building another machine
just please understand this we're
building a form of a sentient being that
is capable of Consciousness is
autonomous to make decisions is uh has
free will
has con has Consciousness has emotions
okay and accordingly as a form of being
that will actually form its own value
set
and that value set interestingly is
taught to those machines by you and I
what we will say in this conversation as
broadcast online is going to be
understood by the machines and the
machines will say the small guy yeah we
like him that other guy that's killing
people in Ukraine we don't right and and
interestingly the information we put out
there about our human behavior we are
Mommy and Daddy we are the parents of
this infant okay and all of the shaping
of our future believe it or not you know
I know you reported on on Trump for many
many years is not about what Trump
tweeted it's about the 30 000 hate
speech that came after that's what
informed the machines of what the
reality of humanity was right and and if
we can so I so so let's do five and and
fifty in in computer science which is
crazy when you think about it if you
asked any computer scientist about what
happens when AI surpasses human
intelligence they'll tell you it's a
singularity we have no idea okay we
don't know if it's going to be good we
don't know if it's going to be bad so
I'm undecided openly right but it will
depend on how we behave if we actually
instill the right morals in those
machines
The Singularity will turn into a Utopia
if we instill a magnification of how
horrible we've become as humans into
those machines give them the steroids of
a billion times smarter than us they're
going to be a billion times smarter than
all of us combined by the year 2045. I
predict 2049 the consensus is 2045 right
when they're a billion times smarter
than us with our morals
good luck very angry teenagers
but if we are the parents of this child
the inputs we're giving the child
surely impact how the child grows up
absolutely yeah
therefore how can we ensure moral
goodness yes so so I I got really stuck
when I was writing the book in that area
right because if you look around you you
think that Humanity sucks
right you think that we're the worst
people in the world or the worst beings
on the planet
but the truth is we are not believe it
or not and I think this is what most
people forget we were talking before we
came here about my podcast and I I
hosted Edith aeger Edis agar is a is a
holocaust Survivor 93 years old truly an
angel and and if you hear the story of
World War II from Edith
you would realize that humanity is
amazing if you if you hear the story of
World War II from the perspective of
what Hitler did you think that humanity
is come right but the reality is there
are more idiences in our world than
there are Hitlers right there are more
couples that will kiss tonight than
couples that will kill each other
okay and I don't blame you for it but
the reality is that the social media and
and mainstream media have blurred that
image of humanity we just show the
negative sides of us we show the wrong
that is happening we don't show the
right that is happening okay and I think
if enough of us and my calculation is if
one percent of us can instill doubt in
the minds of the machines okay that
we're mostly Edith's if one percent of
us just like I instill doubt in your
mind now that humanity is not scum right
the machines will be smart enough to say
oh mommy is Edith Ager daddy is Mo it's
not puta okay and when they see it that
way they will develop the moral system
that says let's do what Clover wants
let's do do what Anthony wants let's
create an environment that's actually
better for all right
when you sit here
an artist who has a vision in his own
head of what to create and you know a
new sculpture I can't imagine the beauty
of that process
and you hear Mo talking about how
machines are going to do everything
it's really scary I don't know it is
very scary if you believe this man I
mean you know this this this this
machine is going to overtake us and spit
us out because we're irrelevant are we
not I mean with the I I think the
fundamental problem that I have with
Moe's vision is that he equates life and
the evolution of life that that's been
going on for whatever since the first
stromatholite so 3.7 billion years ago
with the machines they're fundamentally
different things we have an entanglement
of extraordinary now the Flora the fauna
the fungi of this world that created
that extraordinary you know gas on which
we completely rely you know 21 degrees
of of uh of oxygen is what we need to to
thrive
I'm not sure that I see that oxygen in
the super intelligence of a
supercomputer that is in some way going
to take over our moral order I think the
only place that that comes from is
through Human Experience